By C-A-D-I-T numbers continue to drop, but by tumor size seems to remain the same.
Can you help explain the reason behind this and what to look for?
I've been reading about other alternative treatments for paedcreatic cancer,
specifically in terms of paedcreatic cancer.
Can you please speak a little on the following low-dose nail trexone,
like one allergic acid? Okay, so remember, the definition of cancer is cells that are in rapid replication.
Definition of cancer is cells that are in rapid replication.
If your cells are in rapid replication, then the tumor will be getting larger over a period of time.
And it will get larger over a period of time depending on the rate of rapid replication.
So if it's a more aggressive cancer, it's going to get large.
It's going to see major changes in size over a period of a month.
If it's a little bit less aggressive cancer, you may see just slight changes in a three month period.
But if you're looking at a CT scan or MRI that's comparing apples to apples over a month or two or three months period,
and the tumor's not getting any larger, then you have to say that the cancer is dramatically slowed the rate of replication.
Because there is some apoptosis taking place. So there is still some replication taking place.
But if it's not getting any bigger, it's not acting as cancer anymore.
So if it's not acting as cancer, meeting in a state of rapid replication, that's a very good thing.
And if that's true, that it's not uncommon that your C-A-19 numbers would drop, or any other tumor markers may drop too.
But everybody wants this cancer to go away.
So this mass is three centimeters round.
And it's still three centimeters round. It's still there.
There's a really good chance. How does the cancer go away?
It doesn't just disappear magically. The cells have to go through some rate of cell death to have the mass go down.
And the rate of cell death has to be greater than the rate of cell replication.
So normally the reason why, after you're an adult, your finger doesn't get bigger when you're, isn't it a bigger, when you're 50 years old, that it was when you're 30 years old, is because the rate of cell replication is equal to the rate of cell death or apoptosis.
It's not getting any larger. So same thing with a cancer. If it's not getting any larger, then the rate of apoptosis is equivalent to the rate of replication, meaning it's not even acting as a cancer anymore.
So it's falling off the definition of cancer. Is it still a cancerous tumor that's there? Yes. Is it acting like a aggressive cancer anymore? No. Will it ever disappear? Quite possibly no.
The only thing that will cause it to disappear is that if your rate of cell death greatly exceeds the rate of replication, even normal rate of replication.
That's why chemotherapy tends to shrink tumors because it's very caustic, it's very poisonous, and it will kill the cancer cells.
So you don't get apoptosis, which is normal programmed recycling of normal cell death taking place, you get cell lysis, which is a pathological cell death, which I guess that's not bad when you're talking about cancer, we don't want it to be there.
So we don't care if it pathologically dies, but it's not necessarily necessary unless the cancer is in a spot and the size of it is impeding physiological function of something.
Pressing an artery here, it's pinching a nerve or something like that. It's not impeding physiological function.
Like let's say the cancer is in your pancreas, and it's not impeding physical function. It's not causing you any symptoms, but it's still three centimeters around. Do we care if it stays three centimeters around for the next 40 years?
I hope you don't. I mean, if you're obsessive, compulsive about having it be gone, you could make some great mistakes and do things that could damage other healthy cells in order for you to be satisfied with it being gone.
If you were just satisfied with it, not being growing like a cancer by definition, you could live a normal healthy physiological life, and that's what we have to kind of change our focus on.
So if our if our tumor markers are dropping in the cancer is not replicated faster than it's died. Therefore, it's staying the same size. We should be rejoicing. So is there anything wrong with tried other things? No, no, but I would not try them in lieu of what you're currently doing, because whatever you're currently doing, it must be working.
So, and I'm not saying it's the right and the supplements, maybe it was the chemo. I don't know, but whatever it is that you were doing that have been doing is working to slow this growth.
Comet, he done some of these things, low dose, no traction has been cited as something that can be good for cancer patients, low, no traction at 50 milligrams was a medication that was used to help get people off of morphine and some other addictive substances, but at low dose, it was found to help be an immune system modulator.
So it can help calm an over active immune system, it can help stimulate an under active immune system. Now theoretically, that can be good for cancer if the person's immune system is so suppressed that they need that stimulation if they're really ill, but someone who's not in that state, which I, which you are not, I don't think low dose, no traction would be a wise decision. This is my opinion.
Low dose, no traction is more aptly used in auto immune conditions when people have a hyper functioning immune response that's causing a huge and huge inflammatory response, let's say in rheumatoid arthritis, low dose, no traction can help calm that down.
Eligiac acid is the main constitute of that is public reddit that is in our phase two and pond one assist as well, but that is a still a good product and it's it really helps with phase two detoxification.
Life one I'm not familiar with, 7, 14X I've read about, but I can't really comment, I don't know enough about it to comment on that.